Hello, everybody. This is section nine. Congratulations for coming this far to the stop fighting cancer book. I hope you are learning a lot.
This is Dr. Cutters. Again, if you have any questions, you can call our office. We cannot answer the questions and give you advice without you being a patient, but we can at least point you in the right direction.
If we at all possibly can, so feel free to contact us or contact our website. Today we're going to be talking about pro and anti-oxidants and why anti-oxidants are important for your body.
What's the difference? So this section you'll learn a little about that. Probably the number one anti-oxidant in your body is glutathione and there are some very specific ways that you can stimulate glutathione production.
I used to say that you can't take glutathione just directly because it doesn't absorb through your body. Now, how glutathione works is intracellular inside the cell itself.
So all your cells have glutathione production that help attach onto pro-oxidants that damage these free radicals that damage your cells and can be what leads to cancer and can increase cancer growth.
So the list of some dietary antioxidants are on this picture. So there are good things to take. Vitamin A, C, E, bioflavidoid, co-Q10, glutathione is probably the most powerful.
So how do you get glutathione? Well, I used to say the only way that you can get glutathione is to take glutathione, stimulants and glutathione by products that you need to make glutathione.
Normally in your cell you make your own glutathione, glutathione that acts on a free radical to reduce it and it becomes reduced glutathione and then it upcharges back to glutathione.
So taking alpha-lopeic acid and some other stimulants to help push that process through is the only way to take it.
So now they have some glutathione on the market designs for health has one that you can buy through our web store that is better absorbable so it will work better on the tissue.
So if you buy a cheaper glutathione that maybe one of the local vitamin stores are through target or Walmart, you're not going to get that same benefit and you're really not going to get much use out of that glutathione.
The other thing to make sure with cancer is a little bit controversial and I talk about it in my book.
I want understanding the kind of fats to eat when you have cancer.
So you want to mainly concentrate with cancer on fats that will bring oxygen into the cells because that's what you want to do with cancer.
So normally if a person has a traumatic brain injury or we're dealing with a child with ADHD or something or someone who doesn't have cancer we use omega-6 supplementation that's fish oils.
But with a person with cancer we quite often they can still be taking some omega-3s but we want to be adding some parent essential oils.
So a parent essential oil is a high quality sunflower sunflower pumpkin seed, flax seed, coconut oil, almond oil, walnut oil, you see on this list.
But there had to be high quality there to be organic cold pressed very very important.
So just by going and by crisco or something like that oil in the store says sunflower oil that is not what we're talking about.
That is not the kind of oil you want.
So basically any standard grocery oils are not good for you.
Those are bad fats.
So we talk about good fats, bad fats we want to really the best fats are the organic cold pressed parent essential oils.
So this is what the cancer patients so it's a little bit different with the heart patient and it's a little bit different with the brain patient so understand we're talking about cancer.
Now you can buy these parent essential oils through our store, you can buy them online as well.
But that's what I would suggest.
Sometimes it's good just to take coconut oil straight couple of tables with a coconut oil every day.
It's very helpful for you.
So we want to increase our antioxidants very, very important and really the one of the most natural ways that we increase our antioxidants is go back to last lecture about our diet.
So when we're eating a lot of greens and we're eating whole foods is close to the way God made them.
We don't really have to worry about a lot of other supplementation.
So the best way to get our supplements is through good food.
I would always rather have somebody especially if they're strapped financially to spend their money on good organic produce than buying supplement pills.
So just always keep that in mind.
I hope you learned something from this section when you read it and always were here for you so just know that as well.
I'll see you next time.